good afternoon and welcome to our
session today my name is mary bozzini
and i'm the associate director of
marketing for cancer and translational
research at life technologies
it's my pleasure to moderate this
afternoon's talk which will be presented
by my colleague dr steven jackson
associate director of product
applications in the genetic analysis
division of life technologies
dr jackson's presentation today will
cover high precision analysis of her2
copy number variation and other
applications using the quant studio 3d
digital pcr system
please feel free to use the bio
conference chat functionality to forward
any questions that you would like to ask
dr jackson to address
and we'll save some time at the end of
the printation for q a
and without further ado i'd like to pass
the podium over to dr jackson
thank you mary um
and um thank you for that introduction
and um thank you everybody for uh for
joining our conference
um as mary mentioned i'm going to talk
today about the quan studio 3d digital
pcr system our new introduction into the
digital pcr field in particular i'm
going to emphasize how digital pcr can
be used to look at her2 copy number
variability in
thank you mary in particular i'm going
to talk to you about how the digital pcr
system can be used to analyze copy
number variability in different cancer
applications um and just to re-emphasize
it's going to be covering some
information on her2 copy number
variability as well as some gene
expression analysis and rare allele
detection which can be uh used with the
the quant studio 3d system
so pcr has come a long way in the 30 or
40 years since it first was introduced
back when i was in graduate school i was
one of the people that had three
different temperature water baths
and i took a a set of tubes from one
temperature to the other just by passing
it from one water bath to the next
and that was a wonderful technique for
uh doing endpoint analysis of the
presence of epsom nucleic acids we uh
the agarose gel was was beautiful you
were able to get very nice results using
that method
um over time people began to realize you
could analyze pcr in real time and get
some more semi-quantitative information
by doing a real-time analysis of
fluorescence variability over the course
of a pcr reaction
that has been the gold standard pcr for
the last uh
about decade or so um and over the last
maybe about five to ten years we have
realized that you can do a limiting
dilution
of your nucleic acid and by counting uh
pcr uh reactions that are either
positive or negative uh you can get some
absolute quantification and some digital
uh data from your pcr data this this
represents the final um uh evolution of
pcr from a a very simple system to
something that's quite sophisticated and
very high throughput
um so the the attributes of of digital
pcr the weight differs from traditional
pcr is first of all sensitivity digital
pcr is literally detecting single
molecules in a small well okay and
because of that we're looking at at the
the total number of molecules are
present in a single volume and the the
data that you generate is is driven that
the results are driven by the data or
that the volume of of material that you
that you
interrogate
digital pcr is also uh extremely
specific um i love this particular
illustration here we have a bed of red
tulips and there's one yellow tulip in
that sea of red if you just look at this
from a
far distance away you'd be able to see
just the red tulips without being able
to pick up that one yellow tulip however
by partitioning the screen into
individual tulips you're able to see
that there's a lot a lot of red ones and
one individual yellow tulip and it's
that yellow tulip the ability to
discriminate that yellow tulip that
makes digital pcr very uh
specific
and finally digital pcr because it's
accounting technology is extremely
precise and your confidence in your
results are simply driven by the number
of counting reactions that you do the
more the more accounting that you do
that the better off your results are
going to be typically digital pcr
requires a large number of several
thousands of different individual pcr
reactions in order to generate results
that have a good statistical
significance
so the way the digital pcr works is that
you start off by setting up a regular
pcr reaction in a tube
um
so you just set up a pcr reaction using
the tacman assays and your um
sample
the next step is that you distribute it
into individual wells okay in the case
of our system we have twenty thousand
individual small reaction volumes
and the theory is that you get a single
uh target molecule on average per well
now because of poisson statistics some
of those wells are going to be empty and
some of them are going to have molecules
in them
but it doesn't matter very much because
what happens is that you take this whole
distributed chip and then you subject
subject that to pcr uh reaction you just
go through the thermal cycling
the wells that have a target in there
will be amplified
the wells that have no target in there
will score negative
and in the final result what happens is
that you wind up counting the negative
reactions and by using a a statistical
calculation you can figure out how many
of the wells have an actual signal in
them by by
looking at negative wells the number of
wells that are filled and the number of
total wells that you have
at life technologies we have decided to
take a very simple approach to uh the
digital pcr workflow as i mentioned
before the first step is you simply make
a tube that has your your standard pcr
reaction in it you mix up your assays
with your sample
and your um uh master mix it has the
enzyme and nucleotides in it
then you load it onto the pcr chip and
i'll show you close close up of that in
a second you put it on the pcr machine
to undergo the amplification reactions
and then you read it in our reader
that the pcr
machine that you see there on the screen
is one of our standard pcr reactions
it's been around for quite a while i'm
sure you've seen it before and it fits
very easily on the bench
the reader is about the size of a shoe
box and it also is designed to fit very
easily on a on a bench top um it doesn't
require any extra computers or anything
else it's a totally self-contained unit
and it is is designed to be a very
unobtrusive in your laboratory
i'll tell you that the system is is uh
completely sealed once you put the the
reactions on the chip we'll see that
that has um uh implications in a second
um there's very lit very limited
hands-on time necessary and because it's
sealed there's minimal sample loss
and as i said life technologies decided
to make a conscious choice to have a
sealed chip instead of making droplets
as some of our competitors do
the droplet-based technologies require a
uniform emulsion of droplets being made
and several additional pipetting steps
to setting up the reaction now because
this emulsion can be variable and
because these uh extra pipetting steps
it can also introduce variability um the
the
droplet-based systems
um require uh more workflow and more
analysis than our system does
so as i mentioned this is the the
close-up of our chip
it's a piece of silicon it has about
twenty thousand individual uh reaction
wells in it and like i said all these
will partition a pcr reaction into those
20 000 individual wells
we seal up the chips so that there's
minimal sample loss
in other words once you put your
reaction onto the chip
there can be no contaminating amplicons
or other um
things that get in there to to give you
false positives
again with some of the droplet-based
systems um they're open and you'd have
to do some extensive washing to make
sure
that the previous sample doesn't uh
um uh contaminate your next sample when
you put it through the reader
um our system is designed to handle one
sample at a time and it's designed to to
allow you to duplex meaning you can look
at two assays
per sample per chip so you can have a
vic and a fan floor at the same time
um it's simple and consistent loading
you you wind up
putting all the pcr reaction onto the
chip itself and therefore you don't have
any kind of dead volume that gets lost
in tubes
as i mentioned the sealed consumable
make sure that there's minimal
contamination
um each chip of course it comes with a
unique identifier number which is read
by the reader and it is then a sample
track throughout the whole process
and uh because that the reaction volume
is fixed there's minimal upfront sample
preparation time so it's a very easy and
very straightforward workflow
so some of the advantage of digital pcr
is that first of all it provides an
absolute quantification we are literally
counting the number of molecules that
are present in your sample and this is
without the need to do a standard curve
or any kind of reference uh samples or
uh uh assay in other words you don't
have to calculate the delta c t relative
to actin or gap d h or something else
we're literally looking at the number of
molecules of that particular target that
are present in on the chip
this is particularly useful for
reference laboratories if you want to
quantify nucleic acid standards i'll
show you an example of a gene expression
analysis experiment where we can see
that without having to use any
calibrator molecule we can clearly see
changes in expression level of a gene
and finally related to the her2 story
we're going to talk about how absolute
quantification can help you with copy
number determination
experiments
digital pcr is also useful for that rare
allele detection in other words for
pulling out that yellow tulip from the
sea of red tulips um this allows you to
then look at proto-oncogenes that are in
a few cells in ffpe
tumor samples and another example i will
show you is a chimerism and leukemia
transplant transplant patients where
we're determining whether or not there
are any residual recipient cells after a
bone marrow transplant
finally digital pcr can reduce the
contribution of molecules that interfere
with traditional quantitative pcr and
there are several possible reasons for
this it could be because we're diluting
out the reaction it could be because
we're partitioning the reaction into
twenty thousand individual reactions or
it could be because it's an endpoint and
um instead of a quantitative experiment
uh the bottom line is that it does uh
make the the quantification less subject
to the sorts of inhibitors like heparin
or melanin or other
environmental uh um contaminants
polyphenols for example that can
interfere with quantitative pcr
i'm not going to show very many examples
of this i will mention that the melanoma
samples um it did help with one of our
customers is looking at rare alleles and
melanoma samples
so one word about the sensitivity of the
reaction
the number of rare alleles that you can
detect depends on the amount of
input dna that you supply
in other words if you want to detect one
percent sensitivity okay you have in
other words one molecule out of 100 you
need one mutant allele okay so one one
target mutant in your in your
preparation
and 99 copies of wild-type normal dna
okay now that 99 copies of normal dna uh
total would make about 0.66 nanograms 66
picograms of genomic dna necessary to
achieve a 1 sensitivity so if you want
to detect one allele out of 100 you only
need about 660 picograms of genomic dna
now to get things more sensitive you of
course need more genomic dna and down to
0.001 percent in other words um one in a
hundred thousand
we can still detect one allele but you
need to have 99 999 copies of genomic of
normal genomic dna present that's about
660 nanograms of genomic dna okay so
quite a bit more is necessary
quite a bit more of normal dna is
necessary in order to have the desired
uh sensitivity
what that means is that the sensitivity
depends on the number of partitions that
you can count and the amount of
materials available to be analyzed
for clinical research samples in which
the the amount of genomic dna is
limiting the extremely high sensitivity
is simply not practical or achievable
you just are not going to be able to get
more than a couple hundred nanograms out
of a clinical biopsy or circulating free
dna
okay so um this is an example of how
reproducible that the uh the quant
studio 3d platform is in this case we
had four different operators that were
quantifying the same sample okay so 40
different experiments for your different
chips run each the same sample but uh d
individual uh users running ten
different chips what you can see here is
that they're all getting basically the
same number and in fact what you can
tell is that you know that there are
differences in pipetting efficiencies
among different uh different users and
this is this can be more important than
the actual differences in quantification
of that particular sample it's also in
about 140 140 copies per microliter but
you can see that some individuals are
more precise in their pipetting than
others
but the bottom line is that the the
whole reproducibility of the experiment
is extremely high and very little
variability even though there are 40
different chips running four different
users doing this over several different
days
so um this is the results of one of our
collaborators um this is the japanese
institute institute of metrology that
was interested in determining um how
well we can do absolute quantification
they sent us four different samples um
indicated here on the on the y-axis okay
so four different individual samples
they had previously quantified
and uh we were able to to uh correlate
their their quantifications to very high
precision the other thing that we did
was that we took that uh this 10 to the
minus this the 600 600t sample
and diluted it several a million to a
billion fold and quantified you know the
number of of copies per reaction we were
able to obtain with that sample and
again what you can see is that our our
copy number determination our linearity
and our accuracy was extremely precise
the correlation coefficient of that line
is approaching 1.0 so extremely good
correlation
and the slope is right on we expect it
to be it's about a 10-fold difference
between sample to sample the sample
again illustrating how quantitative this
particular assay is
is able to be
so one application of absolute
quantification as i alluded to before is
the ability to quantify
transcripts without their without having
to do a standard curve without their
being calibrator
so way that we did this experiment um
was uh that we were
collaborating with the customers
interested in looking at the expression
of a primary micro rna transcript that
is produced from three perologist loci
okay so three duplications of this
particular primary micro rna in the
mouse genome and he wanted to see how
these different
loci were corresponding to uh alcohol
treatment or how they responded to
alcohol treatment
so what we see down here is the
expression levels of three different um
uh assays against the three different
loci
so again the three different uh uh
replica are the three different um um
like duplications of the gene in the
genome
um one is shown in purple one shown in
blue and one is shown in red and each
one of these assays were in a duplicate
so you can see that the the correlation
between the measurements is quite tight
also that you can see that the the
primary precursor number one and primary
precursor number three really wasn't
responded to ethanol
after a 15-minute treatment
after one hour withdrawal or after six
hour withdrawal
whereas the uh the primary transcript
number two showed a strong increase in
expression after 15 minutes and it
stayed high after a one hour or six hour
withdrawal
similarly uh with a different time
course
the the primary transcript number two
showed uh you know the same level of
expression before starting but after
alcohol induction it went up um after
six hours and stayed high after six
hours of the six hour withdrawal and
after a 24 hour withdrawal whereas the
other two loci didn't really have the
same
kinetics
so
again that the the quant studio 3d
produced a clear and reproducible change
in the abundance of these different
transcripts produced by uh duplications
of the same locus and we were able to
see that only one of the loci was
responsible to
alcohol
this was done without the need of a
standard curve or with a gap dh or actin
or other kind of reference gene
and this is one of the things that the
absolute quantification can do for you
it will free up the your uh the number
of experiments you need to run the
number of assets you need to do in order
to be able to analyze gene expression
levels
okay so another thing that the the
digital um
pcr can do for you is a a
high number or high precision copy
number variability analysis to
illustrate this we're going to talk
about her2 amplification breast cancer
samples now as most people are listening
to this probably no her2 is a gene um
that is amplified in breast cancers and
other types of cancers and the ability
to amplify or to to measure the
amplification of her2 is important
because it allows us to see whether or
not a patient is going to be able to
respond to a drug therapy like herceptin
um it might be an indicator of other
types of cancers like the metastatic
gastric cancers are can also have her2
amplification
and can also be an indicator of the
prognosis of the patient how well that
that patient uh outlook is going to be
so the more the her2 is amplified the
poor the prognosis of that patient is
going to be and of course that's
something we wanted to be able to
communicate
traditionally her2 amplification is um
done by one of two techniques either
immunohistochemistry
where you um
start your immunohistochemical immune
chemistry reaction you look at the
levels of her2
protein product present and then based
on the levels it's either negative
positive or it's equivocal meaning that
you can't really tell whether or not
it's amplified
and if if you get uh this equivocal
pathway then you would have to go on and
do an orthogonal uh method like inside
your hybridization or something else to
to get a firm indicator whether or not
these equivocal samples have the
amplification
the other method which is commonly used
is in situ hybridization
in this case what happens is that you
perform the experiment and based on the
ratio of her two uh positive chromosomes
to a calibrator chromosome in most cases
uh it could be something like a
chromosome seven uh
centromeric sequence
um you determined that the the number of
copies of her2 the number of copies of
that particular uh calibrator if it's
less than a particular number score is
negative if it's greater than a
particular number then it's scored
positive and again if it falls into this
equivocal range of 1.8 to 2.2 then you
should repeat the experiment to define
to find out whether or not there's
actual repeat there
okay
so
um
this investigator wanted to see whether
or not he could use digital pcr to
refine his ability to to call amplified
her2 loci the reason is that digital pcr
provides technical improvements where
the partitioning enables detection of
single molecules
it is um
easier to perform inside your
hybridization the probes themselves are
very long the whole method about
about
performing hybridization the analysis is
is very tricky it's sensitive to intake
to uh dna damage the cells have to be
synchronized and it's it's difficult to
analyze low abundance targets
with digital pcr those uh those um
problems are not uh um
relevant
um there's it's a very objective
platform or very objective platform so
you don't have inter-observational uh
inter-observer variability in other
words it's it's less subjective and and
it's easy to standardize
and it's less simple less sensitive to
sample sample variability because dna
degradation is not very important in
doing a digital pcr experiment
now because it's easier to do it it
reproduces cost improvements because of
reduced staff time reduced patient
loss of material
it reduced reagent costs and it reduces
the number of sample repeats that you
have to do so overall it reduces costs
so there's a big drive to try to uh to
move from inside your hybridization to
digital pcr for performing her2 copy
number
analyses
so again this is the current state of
the system
um
most users will start off with an
in-situ hybridization
if there is a ratio of her2 to the to
the centromeric locus of greater than
2.2 it's scored as her2 positive
if it's less than 1.8 squared is her to
negative and if it's between 1.8 and 2.2
it's squared is her too equivocal
as i mentioned others might use in situ
hybrid as our you know histochemistry to
look for an amplification but that is
very subjective because it's difficult
to quantify the amount of staining that
you get so the question is can digital
pcr provide a more accurate uh
method of
analyzing her2 amplification
so to do this experiment we obtained a
series of samples from dr bruno ping
um there were 48 samples that were
required this is over the course of
about three years these were ffpe
samples the extracted dna from these
ffpe specimens
we analyze genomic dna by digital pcr
using a her2 assay and an rna's p assay
we use this because the chromosome 17
locus used traditionally in inside your
hybridization experiments is a highly
repetitive sequence
and therefore not suitable for digital
piece or for pcr reactions at all
um we we then um uh
ordered the the results from um from
high from lowest per 2 to rnasp ratio to
highest heritage rnap ratio and along
the x-axis here we just have an
enumeration of the of the 48 different
samples
and what you can see is that there are
samples that very clearly fall into the
asco ratio or at the asco recommendation
of greater than 1.8 meaning that these
samples here
are amplified
these samples here are not
amplified
but these samples that are here in the
center
fall between the the 1.8 to 2.2 ratio
that the the asco
american society of clinical oncologists
recommends as having a her2
amplification so these would be in the
equivocal category okay
but one thing i'd like to mention is
that
um let me
do something here
so if we think about what these ratios
actually mean a ratio of two means that
there are uh twice as many copies of
her2 as um as rna's rnasp
since rnase p is is present in two
copies in a normal diploid genome that
means there are four copies of her2 in
these samples
so
what what asco is calling amplified
means there there's you know uh two
copies um extra of of the genome instead
of even just one
a one point five fold uh ratio would
mean that there are three copies of her2
and only two of the rnasp so one of the
things that the the asco recommendations
miss is a potential uh simple
duplication where three copies of her2
in addition if there are samples that
are um heterogeneous in other words
there are a few cells that have a high
amplification in the background of a
large diploid population
we would probably not be able to detect
those either
since the their
those ratios could be hidden um based in
in in the sea of of of normal diploid
samples so having this induced this
increased sensitivity where we can see
ratios of between say one to one point
eight these are all potential amplified
um
patients you know having having at least
some cells present in their sample that
have been amplified and we'd like to be
able to see whether or not these um
actually are our targets for
either therapies or interventions
so to analyze these samples further dr
ping went ahead and did inside your
hybridization on all the samples and
again just to remind you these are the
samples
these are the samples that were
amplified these are the samples that
would be qualified as not amplified and
these are the ones that are equivocal
now notice down here at the bottom these
are the results of the silver inside
your hybridization results okay and in
fact he's able to score of at least five
more samples that were having an
amplification that were missed if we
just rely on the normal asco standards
in addition there are two samples here
which differed from from what the ask a
recommendation was
sample number 34 was called negative
when in fact it had a ratio of 1.5
and um and sample number 22 was scored
positive even though its ratio was 0.7
so he went back and looked at those
further and found that
sample number 34
um
actually double checked and and found it
did indeed have an amplification but it
turns out that it had one copy lost of
rnasp
so it actually had had uh
one copy of rnasp
and and two copies of the um of the her2
locus so this would not be be classified
as an amplification be reclassified as a
um as a deletion of rnasp
um instead of a instead of a
uh a bona fide amplification in fact we
confirmed that that this was a normal
diploid sample for um a different locus
app and we calculated the ratio of her2
to app we found that it was normal and
indeed not amplified
the other sample sample number 22 uh
scored positive when in fact the ratio
suggested it was negative and when dr
ping went back and looked at that he
found out the sample was mislabeled okay
and it turns out that it actually was a
negative sample
we re-extracted dna and re-ran it and in
fact it reproduced the results so um
he reclassified that one
okay and in fact you know as a result we
found that these two samples then um
were uh
properly adjusted
and uh and
uh the the results were confirmed um of
the inside hybridization by using
additional pcr results in addition the
digital pcr was able to identify several
more samples which were
her2 positive and would have been missed
by
by using the asco cutoffs
so what dr ping suggests is that digital
pcr allows you to save the work
save on on screening because of two
things
first of all um if you just do digital
pcr first you can find those samples
quite easily which are amplified or
amplified or un amplified
he suggests that the the um cutoffs for
those equivocal uh samples should be
between 1.1 and 2.2 and only these need
to be ample or analyzed now by in situ
hybridization saving a lot of work
because instead of analyzing 48 samples
by incitro hybridization instead of
analyzing 48 samples by in situ
hybridization
he only has to analyze 15 samples
so he suggests this is a working digital
pcr
workflow
start off with digital pcr
identify a ratio of of her2 to some
reference gene i'll have more to say
about that in a second if the ratio is
less than one these score negative and
and the samples can be moved on
if the ratio is greater than 2.2 then
you can move on
if there if the ratio is between 1.1 and
2.2 then these samples can be called
equivocal and then you move on to do in
immunohistochemistry inside your
hybridization determine um by an
orthogonal test what the amplification
status is okay
and and by doing visual pcr up front it
saves in time and saves the workflow
because it is much easier and and much
more um
than inside your hybridization
experiment
now word about the reference genes um
as in most cancers you know the genome
is highly altered and whether or not
rnasp or app is a is a good reference
gene a good indicator of what a normal
diploid status is it's not not well
known it might be dependent on the type
of sample that you're using he
recommends including two reference
chains at least examining two reference
genes to determine uh what the proper
ratios are
because as we saw rnasp or a different
cell might have hpp deleted and if your
reference gene is deleted or altered in
the cancer then you might have a falsely
called
specimen
okay so moving away from the copy number
another application of digital pcr and
oncology is a detection of rare alleles
so the problem is how do you detect a
rare sequence when there's a vast excess
of of another one present in traditional
analog pcr what happens is that you'll
you'll wind up getting a large amount of
the wild type copy or of the the
abundant copy before you see the
presence of the rare copy and in fact
this uh uh amplification of the normal
or the the abundant
target
could swamp out or or even preclude your
ability to detect this rare transcript
here okay so sometimes it's difficult to
detect these rare transcripts by
traditional pcr when there's a large
number of normal or abundant transcripts
present that can compete with your uh
rare transcript
now by digital pcr again what we do is
that we sequester the molecules and
individual reactions amplify them up and
because one well now has a single copy
of the rare locus there's no way for
these abundant uh normal uh or or wild
type alleles to compete with their
ability to amplify this this rare
transcript
so diluting out sequestering out um uh
targets into individual reactions allows
you to uh gives you the ability to
detect rare sequences in the background
of a large number of normal sequences
now our software provides a very uh
visual readout of how this works um this
is an example of a of an experiment
we're detecting two not so rare alleles
i should say
but we designed pcr probes that detect
one one allele that's detectable with
fam dye
then another allele that's detectable
with vic dye then we simply sequester
them in 20 000 reactions and measure the
the fluorescence okay and these are the
results here
the wells in in this cloud or the the
the points in this cloud derived from
the wells that have been amplified have
allele a present in them
the wells that are in this particular
cloud have allele b
these wells that are colored in green
have both a and b in them so they
received a little bit of both
and these wells down here the ones that
are empty and wound up having no uh no
target neither a nor b are present in
those wells and again by by counting the
number of empty wells relative to to the
fam signal and the number of wells are
relative to the vic signal we can
quantify the number of rare alleles and
wild type alleles that are present and
the ratio of the rare to the wild type
and since there's only one target per
well having a vast excess of one allele
does not interfere with the detection of
the other allele
so to illustrate this i'm going to have
two examples the first one is based on
leukemia
where we're looking at
quantifying chimerism in bone marrow
transplant patients now kymerism occurs
in leukemia patients when hematopoietic
stem cells or supplement cells i should
say from the recipient and the and the
bone marrow donor are present in the
recipient's bone marrow at the same time
primarism is routinely analyzed after
stem cell transportation and increased
chimerism after transplantation is an
indication of a relapse in other words
the the patient's starting cells are
repropagating the bone marrow
non-relapsed patients show a progressive
decrease in chimerism and it eventually
falls below the detectable levels in
peripheral blood
so for this experiment um the
investigator dr minis velasco out of
malaga spain
um
designed seven different assays and
these were not against particular genes
they're simply against regions where the
the donor had a no allele another the
donor was deleted for this this
particular region
and the recipient had an insertion in
other words the recipient had had the
the uh the insertion so we're very
easily able to distinguish the the donor
from the recipient
we collected samples from the donor and
the recipient before the transplant and
from the recipient at very time various
times after the bone marrow transplant
and we determine the presence of the two
low science samples by digital pcr at
various time points after the transplant
this is an example of one patient or one
study
this
pre-sct is the amount of
signal from the recipient's bone marrow
starting uh before the transplant this
is pre-stem cell transplant okay so 100
percent of the of the
loci we detected were from his
bone marrow
the next
point here this is from the donor you
can see he has much much less you know
the down around undetectable levels of
of the same locus in his uh bone marrow
and then 25 41 101 118 days after
transplant that the recipients bone
marrow or
circulating
recipient cells were analyzed for the
presence of either the donor genotype or
the recipient genotype you can see after
25 days we're detecting mostly the donor
after 41 mostly donor after 101 days
mostly donor but after 118 days we're
starting to see that the recipient cells
repopulate the bone
the bone marrow and also be detectable
in circulation indicating this this
patient was having a relapse and in fact
it was a relapse
that this patient went through and had
to undergo more treatments
this is a summary of the entire study
where we have the seven different loci
that were analyzed in eight different
patients these are the seven loci down
here the samples from the seven
different patients
we have the starting pre-stem cell um
frequency
indicated by the points up here oops
indicated by the points at the top of
the graph
indicated by these points here
okay so this is the recipient frequency
this is the donor frequency down here at
the bottom and you can see that relative
to the recipient they're very different
um
uh percentages of chimerism that are
detectable in other words the donors
have have undetectable or very very low
amounts of of the same locus
and then each one of the points
following that are the recipients
blood
genotype various times after the
transplant you can see that some
patients are having a relapse and some
patients did not have a relapse this is
a very very good way for quantifying the
amount of chimerism present in these
patients
by by just making use of digital pcr and
i have to say that you could do the same
thing with with traditional quantitative
pcr in fact this is what doctor
reminisce velasco was doing for a while
but he wasn't able to have the same
sensitivity he wasn't able to see these
rare events
of of the recipient
genotype coming back up in these early
stages like he was able to see with
digital pcr and that's because there's
so much the donor that was there that
was swamping out the signal from the
recipient digital pcr was allowing him
to see the repopulation of the of the
recipient's blood cells with the
recipient's genotype before
regular traditional pcr was able to
the next set of experiments come from dr
eric springer in mainz germany um in
this case he was looking at ffp
ffpe preserved cancer specimens from
papillary thyroid carcinoma and
malignant melanomas
he was interested in trying to quantify
the number of v 600 e b raf mutations
that he was finding in these different
cancer types and he has for a couple of
years he's developed this arms pcr which
is amplification refractory mutation
system pcr
almost as complicated to
perform as it is to say
but his issue with arms pcr
is that it's difficult and provides
sometimes inconsistent results
okay and so he's interested in trying to
see whether or not digital pcr could uh
provide an alternative to arm's pcr in
and
analyzing these specimens
so he sent us a variety of different
specimens and we analyzed them using a
our rare allele detection system
we had one um
probe that was going to detect the wild
type b raf
allele as you see here and another probe
which would detect the mutant to be
raffled the v600 allele should be
detectable up here in this cloud
these three graphs are three replicates
from uh um the
from the the same tissue slice
this is a wild type piece of tissue and
so we're not detecting any of the mutant
v600e mutation in these samples very
reproducible and and and very um very uh
very low background in this
experiment and this is an example of one
of his papillary uh our thyroid um
samples here
same assays we get a large number of
mutant um i'm sorry a large number of
wild type alleles detected in this in
the sample
but we see a fair number although uh
much fewer uh
numbers than the wild type loci we see a
fair number of wells that scored
positive for the allele
this this means that there is this v600e
mutation present in this in this sample
he confirmed that he was able to see the
same thing by his arms pcr and so uh we
reproduced what he was able to see by
arms pcr in a more quantitative manner
okay we're able to show that there's
point seven percent
of the of the based on the percent wild
type is just simple subtraction he's at
point seven percent of the of the
alleles detected were from the v600 e
mutation
okay
so so not only were able to show the
same uh results that is arms pcr they
were able to show it quantitatively and
be able to get a good indication of how
rare this this allele was in the sample
now
one of his challenging samples are
melanoma samples and these because
oftentimes melanoma genomic dna samples
are contaminated with melanin this is a
poly tyrosine containing uh
glob protein okay which is
interferes with traditional tpcr by by
somehow blocking the activity of
polymerases and it's known that uh the
melanin in samples
can inhibit traditional pcr reactions
in fact by his arms pcr he's able to
show that only eight out of the x team
eight out of the 16 replicates were able
to show a a result because melanin was
inhibiting the activity of polymerase in
his hands
and because digital pcr either you know
is an endpoint acid or because it do
dilutes out the contaminants
or you know whatever we had much higher
success rate with the digital pcr
samples than we were with the uh
arms pcr samples
in other words a very clear indication
that these samples had that the v600e
mutation in the melanoma
reproducible because we're able to see
you know that the same results in
replicates so melanin was not really
interfering with our ability to quantify
the amount of
mutant allele present in these samples
and
for this reason doctor screen concluded
that the pcr that did the digital pcr
system is superior to nested arms if a
pcr inhibitor is present and we found
similar sorts of things we look at
environmental um samples they're humic
acid present
or we look at other blood samples with
heparin
sds or other sorts of inhibitors
additional um
pcr samples digital pcr is much less
sensitive to those inhibitors than
traditional pcr
so just to kind of conclude my talk here
what i've shown you is that digital pcr
allows you to perform an absolute
quantification nucleic acids without the
use of standard curves or reference
genes
digital pcr can be used to uh to
discriminate between alleles and
heterogeneous samples you can detect
rare alleles
in the background of a large number of
wild type or normal alleles
the counting technology makes digital
pcr extremely precise and reproducible
and digital pcr is
in general less sensitive inhibitors of
traditional real real-time pcr
the quantity of 3d is extremely easy to
use and as i've told you the closed
system helps reduce the chance of
outside contamination
amplicons that are that are present will
not be able to get into the tube once
you have or want to get into the uh into
the chip once you've sealed it up
i've also shown you the quantity of 3d
platform
um can use
the thousands of of pre-designed tacman
assays and protection assays that live
technologies currently has available we
also have the uh
ability to custom design assays for you
for uh for either snippet genotyping for
uh for looking at
um transcripts are not present in our
catalog or other sorts of custom
applications
and the quantity of 3d is designed to
generate high qua high quality and very
quantitative data that facilitates
absolute quantification of nucleic acids
analysis of gene expression copy number
variability determination and rare
allele detection
in a very simple and and very uh cost
effective workflow
i would like to thank our collaborators
uh mr bruno ping from the royal surrey
hospital in uh
uk
dr antonio jimenez velasco from uh the
carlos hyatt hospital in malaga spain
dr eric springer from uh institute for
pathology in mainz germany
dr
ichiro fuji from the national
metrology institute of japan and dr
andre piotrowski from rutgers university
i also thank uh
my colleagues at life technologies that
performed the work and helped us
assemble this lies patricia hendrich
uh sonali patel
kathleen hayashivara and lavorka
tegarizia
finally i'd just like to
say that quanzito3d is for research use
only
and
thank you very much for your attention
and your time
i'll turn it back over to mary for a
second to see if there are any questions
thanks very much steve
um we do have a question that's come in
and
this question is from agnes and the
question is
what is the primary difference between
this digital pcr method
and the standard
abi allele discrimination assays
other than
that with the digital pcr method you're
amplifying in 20 000 wells
so the question is what is the
difference between the the digital pcr
platform and our um our mutation
detection um pcr assays we call um
uh
competitive allele specific
pcr
um the the the
cast pcr works on a
um
real-time system it is basically
performed in a real-time pcr tube in a
volume similar to real-time pcr
assay what happens in that case is that
you're amplifying everything um but the
the allele the ability to detect the
wild type allele is inhibited so at some
point all your
your all you're detecting is that the
normal i'm sorry the mutant locus you're
you're decreasing the signal from the
wild type and only having the wild type
locus detectable
what happens though with uh with more
and more amplification is that you
increase the chances that the wild-type
inhibition is going to stop and you wind
up picking up wild type alleles and in
fact we we see that with our with the
traditional uh mutation detection system
that we have you have to kind of fine
tune where in the real time cycle you
draw the cutoff between between
the number of cycles necessary to detect
the the mutant and the number necessary
to keep the wild type background down
okay in digital pcr you don't have that
problem it's an end point where you
either detect only the mutant or only
the wild type if you have one copy of
each in a well there's no way for the
wild type to interfere or to to
to
compete with your ability to detect the
mutant signal okay that just is not a
problem
i hope that answers the question
mary back to you
thanks steve we have uh
one more question before we wrap up
and
again from agnes the follow-up question
can
can tacman
molecular beacon probes be applied
to this digital pcr
platform
i'm sorry mary i couldn't hear any of
that could you repeat the question
please
sorry about that uh hopefully you can
hear now
the question is whether or not a
molecular beacon type probe
can be applied to
this type of application
the question is whether a molecular
beacon type probe can be applied to this
application the answers is probably yes
our research and development team is
always trying to uh find new ways to
improve our system
and they're they're
you know trying to find new ways to
apply new chemistries to uh increased
sensitivity and and throughput
um i i
would have to say on our particular
system i'm not sure if molecular beacon
was going to be detectable because the
the reader is designed to detect only
vic and fam dyes and i'm not sure how
the questionnaires particular beacon
would be detectable um
in the spectrum that the vic and
famidize are designed to uh to quantify
the the general question to the answer
or answer the question is yes the
technology can be applied to molecular
beacons
uh specifically as applied to our system
uh the answer is probably not but that
doesn't mean that it's not
open to developmental
pathways in the future another question
hi steve can am i being heard at this
point
i hope
there's one last question
before we wrap up
and the question is how can you
determine
or what are the chances of having more
than one target per well
the question is is what are the chances
of having more than one target per well
that really depends on the starting
concentration of what you apply to the
chip
if you apply a large concentration the
chances are going to be very good that
you have more than one copy per well and
as the as the questionnaire is probably
realizing that's going to interfere with
your ability to accurately quantify what
is present in that sample in other words
it's an endpoint asset and you're just
going to see whether or not there's
fluorescence or not but you can't tell
whether or not the fluorescence is from
two three four or five you know
different molecules
so one of the things that that has to be
done in a digital pcr reaction is that
you shoot for this
uh this sweet spot of around uh one copy
per well okay and you can calculate if
you remember from your uh your
microbiology and biochemistry you should
be able to to back calculate the number
of copies present in a particular
mass of a length of
dna or rna sequence
and from that you can then estimate that
the the concentration that that you need
to use and the dilution you need to use
to get to that sweet spot of about one
copy per cell growing copy per well
life technologies is coming out with i
can't tell exactly when it's going to be
present but we have a calculator which
our our customers can use to facilitate
that calculation
if you don't remember your biochemistry
or molecular biology and sometimes i
don't either so
this calculator should be helpful for
for those people who need to
make that calculation and provide you a
ballpark
dilution to start from to make sure that
you're at the sweet spot for accurate
quantification
at this point i want to uh thank uh
steve for his uh very informative
presentation
and more importantly uh thank all of you
for joining us this afternoon
um please if you have uh any questions
about this system
or
other questions uh you can visit us in
the booth we'll be open for another
couple of hours and i wish you a
productive and informative
rest of the conference thank you very
much